so we understand that favor has been
acquired by gravitas that's all right
okay
can you tell us about sort of who
courted whom and
um i went after gravitas absolutely okay
um the pursuer
i did well the what's great about
gravitas and film buff and i think go
digital as well there's a bunch of them
they're not really they're distributors
in name only they're really aggregators
although they're starting as these
companies grow they are becoming more
distributory but what they do is they're
they essentially they function as an
intermediary between
uh hulu itunes uh netflix
um view you know pay-per-view cable
companies uh showtime basically
companies where they don't want to deal
with individual filmmakers you have to
go through a distributor
what they do is they um you get from
dollar one all the
you know the revenue minus their
distribution fee which is great they're
not trying to recoup costs they do have
they do have a clause to recoup costs
but it's capped very low it's super
reasonable it's ridiculously low it's
like office costs
and that way you're guaranteed at least
as the film generates income you're
seeing something from the first
transaction
which is very different than a
traditional distributor where you're
getting they go they may or may not give
you an advance
and they're going to take everything
until they recoup costs and
and then you never see a dime so
um i think gravitas is a good reputation
for i mean first of all do your research
go to your apple tv or itunes and go to
indie movies and
every tuesday and every friday when they
post new trailers and post new movies
and see what's coming out look at the
trailers see who the companies are
that's what i did and gravitas
was consistently present and they had a
nice variety
nice wide range of stuff they were
releasing documentaries foreign films
indies that were about the same size as
favorite indies that were a lot bigger
than favor they had a good spread
um and in dealing with them
they've been they don't they're very
honest very laid back they don't over
promise
that said with a company like this you
are
responsible for most of your advertising
and publicity they do some of it
but not very much they do it as it
pertains to the platforms they're on
they'll put they'll work with you on the
trailer they'll put the trailer on
itunes and put the ads on itunes they'll
fight for the best place when they can
but you're not going to see advertising
that they're not going to place an
advertising on coming soon.net
or anything like that that would be up
to you so it is up to you to sort of
run the charge but it will be up to you
anyway
even with uh even with a distributor
that's doing advertising because unless
you're working something with a big boy
they're going to do as little as
possible as well gravitas
film buff they're honest we're not
responsible for marketing or advertising
um you are we'll do some but here's what
we're going to do
uh but they've they've been really great
to deal with and they're really cool
about
um your timetable your schedule the fact
that you have to do a delivery to them
you deliver elements to them and
contracts and you have to you know get
get you know insurance and all those
things but they're really cool about how
long it takes to get those things
done and they do find ways to get you
um the best prices for things which is
terrific they make
for example uh closed captioning you
have to get close captioning they have a
closed captioning
deal so you can get really reasonable
close captioning done and basically you
just
pay the fee and turn the movie over and
it's set up to take care of everything
you can get your own done
but i researched it it's a lot more
expensive use their guys and you
literally hand them over the movie
dialog list everything's all taken care
of and it's delivered for you and you
own it so if you go to dvd which they
only handle
the digital rights for us if you go to
dvd with a different company
you own that closed caption you can take
that element and apply it to
your dvd or blu-ray or foreign or
whatever else you need to do
they're also really great about dealing
with you know helping develop a trailer
and
just getting on the phone and just
running past ideas we had we were doing
something called the april favor day
campaign because we're coming out on
april 1st
and we had an idea about uh and we'll
be doing a whole promotion for it and
basically saying you know we want you to
try to
if you're gonna run our film or buy it
on itunes can you do it on april 1st
because we want to try to get onto the
itunes
sales charts or rental charts because if
we do we're for more visible
and it really impacts the way the
movie's perceived it'll help us moving
forward with netflix with showtime
it'll you know get us in front of a lot
more eyeballs it basically
it can snowball into the success we want
the film to be
just by that that simple act of getting
on itunes
and so we ran that idea past them like
that's great well we will make sure we
run your promo video and make sure we do
this we should do it this way try this
and
we're able to kind of refine the idea
with them on the phone cost them
you know 10 minute phone call and uh
and we're now kind of more empowered to
do what we need to do
so they're sort of i mean they're sort
of cool they're sort of cool i like them